Critical news.
CNN reporting now
on a potential giant change in US
policy
that could have dramatic consequ
for the battlefield in Ukraine.
Sources telling CNN
the Biden administration
is finalizing a deal
to send American-Made Abrams
tanks to the battlefield.
Senator Lieberman
live at the Pentagon for us on
this is a big shift. What's happ
It is. For a long time, the U.S.
and the Pentagon had said the Ab
tank was not the right fit for t
urging other countries
to send their tanks.
We're now learning,
according to three U.S.
officials, familiar with the mat
that the Biden administration
is now
finalizing plans
to announce
the commitment of sending Abrams
tanks to Ukraine. The U.S.
made M-1 Abrams
tank An advanced but complex sys
that Ukrainian President Volodym
Zelensky has been asking for for
Important for a number of reason
First, the shift in U.S.
policy.
Second,
this is a signal, another signal
I should say, of ongoing U.S.
support for Ukraine
in terms of the weapons and the
it provides.
But perhaps most importantly,
it breaks an apparent logjam
with Germany.
German officials had repeatedly
they would not send
or approve the sending of their
German made leopard tanks until
made a similar move.
Although it
it appeared last week,
German officials
were kind of softening their sta
a little bit on that one.
It's still remained out there.
So this if and when it's announc
and that announcement
could come as soon as this week
would break
that logjam, allowing
not only Germany to send leopard
but also
any of the more than dozen count
that operate leopards,
very much
giving Ukraine
a direct offensive
threat on the battlefield
as the war with Russia enters it
the one year mark.
Also worth noting that the U.K.
has committed
to sending
some of its own challenger to Uk
So this is a
big shift from the administratio
and certainly big news for Ukrai
A big, big reward for Ukraine.
This is what President Zelenskyy
has been asking for saying
I appreciate the thank you
as I need tanks instead.
You mentioned the complexity.
You mentioned
the Pentagon had been resistant
because it's a big system.
It's a gas guzzler.
The logistics and the training i
Walk us through a timeline here
from announcement to deployment.
So this will still take months,
if not even longer than that.
There's little doubt about that.
This isn't likely to come direct
from U.S.
stocks.
It's not likely
to be a presidential drawdown,
especially because the U.S.
just announced
a two and a half billion dollars
drawdown of U.S.
stocks for Ukraine last week.
Instead,
this is more likely to come thro
the Ukraine
Security Assistance Initiative.
What that means is that means is
creates new contracts
with the tank manufacturers,
but that also takes time to manu
the tanks,
to acquire them
and to get them to Ukraine.
So, John, this is not something
we're likely to see happen immed
Ukraine is hoping its Western
allies will send them
German made leopard to tanks,
but Germany has been resisting
so far to do that.
However, Germany has said
they will not stand
in the way
if other countries like Poland
want to send some of their leopa
Joining us now
to explain all of this
and the significant
CNN anchor,
national security correspondent
Jim Sciutto.
This is was all has been all the
in the past
few days in Germany
would technically need
to sign off, right.
On a country like Poland
sending a tank that they made.
They're saying
they're not going to stand in th
Can you explain why these tanks
so much in Ukraine?
Well, it has echoes of the debat
we've seen since the start of th
even going back to 2014
to focus on the next big weapons
You remember all the debate
about sending fighter jets
in the West view
not the right weapon
for this time
requires too much support
Ukraine wanting those weapons sy
And there are a lot of similarit
between that and these tanks now
Let's talk about
why specifically leopard tank
leopard tubes
they certainly have some advanta
One is
they use NATO's standard ammunit
120 millimeters
which makes it a lot easier for
allies to provide that ammunitio
They have more than the Soviet m
that go to the tanks
that Ukraine relies on now.
But the problem is
it requires in general,
I've spoken to former tank
commanders, more support,
more training for the crews
that kind of thing.
So the question
from the view of some U.S.
officials, right.
Is that this is more of a burden
or could be a burden
for Ukrainian forces in the fiel
than an advantage right now.
And the idea to Jim.
Right.
The belief that these leopard tw
are much more effective
on Ukrainian terrain than you at
Right, than the US tanks.
Can you talk about how effective
they fare in the war?
Well, here's the thing.
Tanks have not done well in this
They have to decide.
Russia has lost
and these are conservative estim
Buy or x 600 tanks.
Ukraine, close to 500.
These are almost
certainly underestimates.
But let's take those numbers as
Thousands of tanks
have been destroyed already.
They're big targets.
Ukraine has had enormous success
Russian tanks
in small units
using those javelins
shoulder fired missiles
and now relying on those Bradley
fighting vehicles
that are going in as well.
They have anti-tank weapons.
They're smaller, they're faster.
U.S.
officials believe
that's the way Ukraine
should be fighting this war.
And to kind of make them pinned
with more tank
divisions will make them more vu
because Russia has great anti
tank weapons.
In fact, one U.S.
official said to me
the concern is
that Ukraine will have tank its
tank graveyards
like we saw for Russian forces
at the beginning of the war.
One final note, Poppy.
It's just the numbers
we're talking about here.
Russia has many hundreds of tank
deployed in Ukraine,
more than a thousand.
Poland is talking about sending
Germany has a total of 200
leopard, two tanks in storage.
They're not going to send all of
So those numbers,
you know,
the math in terms of writing,
that balance doesn't quite add u
Really lopsided even if not all
Jim, thanks for that.
Here with me
now, CNN military analyst, forme
supreme allied
commander General Wesley Clark.
General Clark,
good to have you on this morning
Thank you, Jim.
I want to ask
you about the current debate ove
sending leopard
German made leopard tanks to Ukr
Ukraine wants them.
I've spoken to U.S.
officials who question
whether this is the weapons syst
that Ukraine needs now.
In your view, does
Ukraine need these tanks now?
Or should they be
focusing on other weapons system
Well, I mean,
I think Ukraine needs the tanks
now, but they need a lot
of other things now to jump.
What they have been asking for
desperately as long range drones
This is the switchblade 600 dron
It's held up in Department of th
and some sort of
foreign military sales pipeline.
If they had this,
they could disrupt the ammunitio
and so forth behind them.
They need to look for tanks.
They need a self-propelled artil
They probably need
300 to 500 main battle tanks.
We're talking about
maybe getting 100 leopards from
these other years.
They're in a really tough positi
Yeah, that's the concern.
Right, is that the numbers
that Germany in total has 200
leopard tanks in storage right n
Poland is talking about sending
that even if they do get them, g
the numbers
the many hundreds of tanks
that Russia has and Russia's ver
anti-tank weapons systems.
One U.S.
military official said to me tha
the US concern is
that Ukraine will have tank grav
if they try to fight Russia
in this style.
Much like we saw Russia
have those tank graveyards
early in the invasion
Well,
I wouldn't be too concerned abou
because I think the Ukrainians
will keep these tanks
in a mobile reserve
initially and use them only as n
or in a counter offensive role.
But I do say this
the quantity of weapons that we
and the
responsiveness of sending them
is at every stage two steps behi
We say
we are responsive to the battlef
but we're not actually anticipat
the battlefield and go
on a strategic defensive.
It's just a matter of time
until Russia mobilizes forces, m
and gets a breakthrough.
Being made could be further sout
But the Ukrainians know this
and they're fighting,
struggling to maintain
every inch of Ukraine because th
that Putin seeks a political vic
And their military
is not only working for militari
not not an abstract military pro
This is about their morale or na
So these are some really tough q
They deserve our help.
They're fighting for us.
And we should be giving them
one of these types of assistance
they need and do it now.
Well, to your point
about anticipating the battlefie
and CNN's
reporting
that that is exactly
what the West is recommending no
In other words, don't
pour so many resources
and frankly so many lives and bo
into this war of attrition. In d
Focus on
potential offensive in the south
Ukrainian tactics, Ukrainian for
have more success
Sure.
And and I think
for as long as I have talked
to the Ukrainians,
they've looked at this.
And, Jake,
Russia is going after
the land bridge is really import
But if you can't hold the back d
at Vaucluse in Donetsk and on DP
that offensive in the south does
So they've got to try
to hold the back door on their s
whether they hold it tactically,
whether they give up
ten kilometers in Bermuda or som
that that's a tactical decision.
But they can't simply
pull out of this area to the eas
And they're locked in this battl
with heavy artillery
and waves of human assault.
It's a really tough tactical pro
And obviously, as American,
we don't like it,
but that's the war they're fight
Yeah.
And I don't think Americans
are quite aware
of just the human cost of this,
the many hundreds of casualties
for those Ukrainian forces in th
in the general Wesley Clark.
Always good to have you on.
Thank you, Jim.